le malaise il nous fait rire souvent il
nous amuse mais en même temps c'est
toujours un peu désagréable alors le
malaise c'est quoi exactement
c'est un sentiment de gêne et tension
qui apparaît lorsque quelqu'un qu'on
regarde se retrouve dans une situation
très embarrassante
les allemands ont d'ailleurs un mot pour
ça que l'on n'a pas chez nous french
fund tient littéralement ça veut dire
étrangers honte
c'est ce sentiment lorsqu on a honte à
la place de quelqu'un que l'on ne
connaît pas vraiment voire pas du tout
et ces petites cette proximité qu'on a
avec la victime qui différencie le
malaise qui va nous faire rire de celui
qui veut nous faire souffrir et qu'on
veut éviter ça et le contexte sachant
que quand on est seul derrière son ordi
le contexte est souvent favorable au
malaise qui nous fait rire alors que
cissé pendant une marche pour charlie
hebdo la plus du tout et cette notion de
malaise revient en force
il suffit de regarder le fameux malaise
tv qu'on a pu voir sur youtube twitter
ou facebook par exemple où le google
trend autour de l'expression malaison
alors c'est vrai que ma les ans et plus
directs comme mots que dérangeant ou
troublant et pourtant ils sonnent
inventé alors en plus de pas être
créatif il aima les ans c'est parce
qu'il est formé à partir du participe
présent du verbe malaisée on a vraiment
l'impression que ce verbe n'existe pas
et pourtant on voyait déjà dès le xvième
siècle relevé par edmond huguet avec cet
extrait d'une oeuvre d'époque librement
nous voyons nos femmes devises et 115
jaloux soupçon nous viennent malaisée
donc on a droit de le dire malaise en
art comment quelque chose devient ma les
ans la revue scientifique pls world a
publié une étude sur la question
une première expérience vise à savoir si
le malaise était quelque chose qui
pouvait se produire si l'individu
observé avait agi de manière
accidentelle ou intentionnelle et était
au courant ou non qu'il était dans une
situation embarrassante pour lui et bien
dans tous les cas de figure de manière
accidentelle est au courant comme crise
et sur du verglas de manière
accidentelle est pas au courant comme se
promener avec sa part y est ouverte
non
de manière intentionnelle et au courant
comme manger fort dans une bibliothèque
ou de manière intentionnelle et pas au
courant comme portait un t-shirt i'm
sexy and i know it
à chaque fois les observateurs disaient
ressentir du malaise
cela signifie que pour ressentir du
malaise on n'a pas nécessairement besoin
de voir de l'an barrage la personne
observer une seconde expérience a été
menée et cette fois que des tests irm
qui permettent de voir les zones
activées du cerveau lors de cette
expérience on a projeté différentes
situations et observer le cerveau des
participants
on a pu voir que le cortex cingulaire
antérieur et le cortex insulaire
antérieur gauche qui sont deux zones qui
sont impliqués dans le ressenti de la
souffrance par procuration sont aussi
impliqués dans le ressenti de la
souffrance sociale pour les gaffes des
autres mais surtout l'activité de ces
deux zones et positivement lié à
l'empathie en gros plus une personne est
empathique et puis l'activité sera forte
du coup c'est plutôt clair le processus
d' empathie est fondamental pour
ressentir du malaise paradoxalement
c'est parce qu'on a une empathie et
qu'on est capable de se mettre à la
place des gens qu'une scène de malaise
ça peut nous faire rire on peut appeler
ça le paradoxe de malaise
et le fait que voir l'individu dans une
situation mal les ans tu passes à nous
faire ressentir du malaise ça peut faire
penser au concept de neurones miroirs
en gros quand je fais une action
j'active des neurones et bien juste
quand j'imagine faire l'action ou que je
vois quelqu'un vers cette action
j'active aussi une partie de ces
neurones les neurones miroirs il joue
évidemment un rôle dans l'empathie bruce
de la chaîne d'y penser en parle
longuement dans cette vidéo que je vous
mets dans la description
mais le malaise n'est pas là que pour
nous faire rire aux souffrir non il a un
impact bien plus profond que ça quand
une personne est embarrassé lorsque
c'est approprié les autres la perçoivent
comme étant plus digne de confiance et
ses actes comme plus pardonnable
c'est ce qui ressort en tout cas d'une
étude publiée dans la revue scientifique
john orloff brice martin sochaux
alors la prochaine fois que vous êtes
dans une situation embarrassante
pensez bien votre réaction vous pourrez
soit créé un malaise chez ceux qui vous
observent soit gagner leur confiance et
leur donner envie d'être autres potes
quant à moi je vous envoie du love et de
la pisse merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a plu le
format est totalement différent de ce
qu'il ya d'habitude mais je pense que je
la mettrais crémant la playlist des pop
up car c'est ce qui s'en rapproche le
plus vous êtes désormais plus de 200
milles à me suivre et cc merci beaucoup
c'est énorme je vous fais un petit a
fait qu pour l'occasion je n'ai pas
encore de quelle manière je faire ça
mais en tout cas voilà envoyer vos
questions sur twitter avec le hashtag
est fait qu cyrus north
c'est vraiment plus pratique sinon en
commentaires facebook sur le poste de
cette même vidéo et enfin sonné ni
twitter ni facebook et bat en
commentaire de cette vidéo
mais voilà je préfère que les
commentaires de cette vidéo soit une
discussion autour du malaise privilégié
twitter au maximum merci beaucoup et à
bientôt
bisous